احنا عندنا تقديس لبعض شخصيات يعني
بنخليها تعلو درجه عن البشريه عن البشر
وده موجود مش بس في الدعاه الدينيه وايضا
في بعض الزعماء كل ده خطا يعني يعني لازم
ان احنا نكسر الحته دي ويعاملوا كبشر عشان
من اجل من اجل انتعاش الحياه لكن انت لو
قدست خطوط حمراء ممنوع ممنوع انت بتقتل
العقل لا يعني كده اذا انت لم تنتقد ما
قبلك او او تعمل عقلك في اي مقوله فانت
هتبقى تتحول الى ناقل والدنيا هتموت
الحياه بتتجدد بالتفكير مش معنى كده انت
بالضروره يعني عايز اقول انت عندما تقرا
ما يقول الشعراوي مش بالضروري عليك انك
انت تنتقده وممكن توافقه ممكن توافقه بس
بعد بس عندما ياتي عقلك الراجل ده قال
والله المعلومه دي صحيحه ومظبوطه ولا اخضع
لسحره يعني خاصه انه يملك كاريزما هو
ودمه خفيف ايقاع الموسيقي في الاداء
والحركي في اللغه الجسديه عنده ودي مهمه
في مذيعه عنده لغه جسديه تحبه في مطرب
يعني المطرب مش بس صوت والدعايه برده مش
بس صوت
العلاقه الجسديه او اللغه الجسد عند الشيخ
الشعراوي عاليه جدا
من المشاهد لما كان قاعد في القريه بتاعته
حاول يحاكي
دي كلها والف مبارك موجوده على على قيد
الحياه